[Musik]
heute ist in der sternstunde philosophie
ein pianist zu gast und zwar einer der
besten die auf berühmtesten dieser welt
igor levit
[Musik]
ich freue mich auf ein gespräch das weit
über das thema musik hinaus gehen wird
herr lee wird herzlich willkommen freue
mich auch wenn ich sie als pianist
vorstelle weiß damit er nur die hälfte
dessen gesagt was sie als mensch und
künstler ausmacht zum beispiel auf ihrem
intensiv gespielten twitter-account
stellen sie sich folgendermaßen for
citizen european pianist ich nehme an
die reihenfolge sehr bewusst gewählt
voller abpfiff ja was ist ihnen denn
nach dieser reihenfolge so wichtig naja
ich bin zuallererst staatsbürger das so
habe ich mich immer gesehen punkt ganz
einfach und das war dass das ist
sozusagen das ist der grund auf dem
alles alles steht dieser dieses land in
dem ich groß geworden bin
die menschen um mich herum die
strukturen erlaubt mir oder und hat mir
erlaubt und erlaubt mir das zu sein was
ich sein will nämlich frei und musikern
weil diese citizen die man auf deutsch
als bürger übersetzt er hat ja recht
widersprüchliche haltung wir kennen den
wutbürger wir kennen den besorgten
bürger sogar den spießbürger was ist
denn für sie dann das zentrum einer
einer bürgerlichen haltung verantwortung
seinen mitmenschen gegenüber bewusstsein
dafür dass man verantwortlich ist seinem
land gegenüber bewusstsein dafür dass
unsere demokratie vor die hunde gehen
wird wenn wir als bürger versagen und
dieses weltbürgertum von dem man ja auch
spricht ist das für sie auch eine idee
hatte sprachen jetzt für die
verantwortung für das land aber man
könnte das ja auch viel breiter
verstehen produzieren sie mich ruhig
also ich bin
ich bin international unterwegs mir ist
das wort weltbürger zu vage
ich versuche so viel wie möglich die
welt zu spüren und zu erfahren was in
meinem sinne so viel bedeutet wie so
viele menschen wie möglich kennen zu
lernen denn das ist das was mich am
meisten inspiriert und immer schon
inspiriert hat sind menschen dazu
menschen zieht es mich hin von menschen
lerne ich und und erfahre und spüre mich
am allermeisten durch sie durch meine
mitmenschen aber das ist so so so viel
mehr als nur der begriff weltbürger ich
hörte auch aus dass ihnen das
weltbürgertum so wagner und sowohl fall
ist während es ihnen auf eine ganz
konkrete form der interaktion ankommt
die auch immer verortet und situiert ist
ja es kommt mir einfach aufzuhören
ich höre einfach sehr sehr gerne
menschen zu und da war ich höre ihn auch
dass er gerne zu und das zweite wort in
ihrer selbst vorstellung european das
ist ja auch interessant hier sind 1987
in der sowjetunion geboren damals gerade
kollabieren mit acht jahren nach
hannover aus gewohnheit man kann sagen
dass ihre generation eine generation der
fallenden mauern war
ist das für sie auch zentral in diesem
europäischen bekenntnis ja aber ich bin
nicht ich bezeichne mich nicht nur als
europäer mit einer rosaroten brille ich
bin ein sehr kritischer europäer ja weil
das was europa repräsentieren kann und
auch repräsentiert ist teils
wunderschönen und das teils ein
absoluter politischer und
gesellschaftlicher albtraum und den
sollte man auch so benennen was wäre
denn für sie derzeit das kritischste
wenn sie an diesen alptraum europa
nennen das nicht vorhandensein einer
klimapolitik dass das abstürzen
demokratischer werte und die
albtraumhafte
integrationspolitik ich finde das ja
deswegen auch interessant sie sind ja
auch viel in der welt unterwegs dass es
eine art abgrund gibt zwischen der
europäischen selbstwahrnehmung die sehr
kritisches und der wahrnehmung europas
von den anderen kontinenten für die
europa immer noch ein vorbild eine
leitfunktion hat wir können eine haben
wir könnten eine haben aber wir neigen
gerne dazu wehrte nach innen zu
vertreten und nach außen zu vergessen
und ich sehe ein realpolitik ist
realpolitik und bedarf ist bedarf
kompromisse die die schwierig sind
man sollte das aber auch so benennen
man sollte nicht so tun als sei man der
weiße engel mit flügeln der mann nicht
ist und unabhängig davon bleiben wir mal
bei so einem fall die nicht vorhandene
oder die die groteske klimapolitik ist
einfach ein gutes beispiel dafür was wir
tun könnten
und was wir einfach brutal
vernachlässigen und damit einfach
buchstäblich unsere und die zukunft
unserer kinder einfach den bach runter
spielen
diese vorfreude vorreiterrolle
konsequenter und offensiver anzunehmen
dass es wohl eine forderung europas ein
raum der werte kann man sagen ist auch
ein kultureller raum und ein ganz
wichtiges instrument in diesem
kulturraum kulturraum ist das piano das
ist ja auch eine sehr europäische
erfindung was würden sie denn sagen ist
das europäische jahr an ich habe das
nach gelesen ich wusste es nicht
im prinzip ist die erfindung des pianos
gleich ursprünglich mit der modernen ids
europa 1617 jahrhundert ja das ist eine
eine eine europäische erfindung des
spiele zumeist oder sehr häufig musik
von komponisten
die in diesem europa gelebt und gewirkt
haben aber das ist für das sind für mich
maximal zehn prozent der wahrheit
das tolle an das wunderbare musik ist ja
sie ist absolut immateriell der große
komponist pianist denkert philosophie
sony person die bezeichnete musikers
tönende luft wenn ich ihnen jetzt
nämlich sage legen sie musik in die hand
könnten sie das nicht wenn ich ihnen
jetzt aber sagen sie mir das glas wasser
in die hand könnten sie das ist das frei
von jeder ironie das ist musik ist das
was zwischen uns passiert sie ist im
wahrsten sinne grenzenlos und
international und deswegen ich sehe ein
oder oder ich respektiere und unseres an
die traditionen aus denen die musik die
ich mache
er wuchs sind mir sehr wichtig aber
daraus nationale dinger zu drehen das
langweilt mich so sehr dank damit möchte
ich mich nicht beschäftigt diese immer
die realität der musik kann man sagen es
hat ein medium braucht die brücke ins
schwingen die entsteht das zwischen
manchmal sagt ja auch was ist eine
universelle sprache gerade eben weil sie
nicht durch inhalte begrenzt ist können
sie damit was anfangen ja das ist dass
es jetzt mal ein gutes beispiel für
worthülsen
was ist universelle sprache wir neigen
dazu via musiker und und musikschaffende
und und menschen so aus diesem bereich
ja mit sowohl fallen wahrheiten um uns
zu schmeißen wir die welt vereine wie
die friedensstifter wir die die
internationale sprache der musik
sprechen analysieren wir mal in unserem
bereich zumindest mal meinen bereich
dieser sogenannte internationale welt
sprachen aspekt das ist direkt ja zum
was spielen wir dann musik spielen wir
die welt interessieren wir für uns für
sie oder spielen wir maximal zehn
prozent der jemals geschrieben musik und
davon sind 90 von hier eurozentristisch
körper zentristische weiß
zumeist männlich das ist dass wir
suggerieren gerne ein offenes auge und
ein offenes herz aber wir leben es nicht
und die großen welt vor einer und
weltweiter sind ja auch nicht
allerdings kann ich mir vorstellen dass
wenn sich igor levit ans klavier setzt
und für elise spielt das der kinder aus
allen kulturellen hintergründen sofort
spüren ja dass das für sie ist dass sie
angesprochen
aber wissen sie wenn ich am klavier
sitze und diese musik spiele für
menschen die in mir gegenüber sitzt dann
ist mein interesse an jeder musik die
diese menschen mitbringen mindestens
genauso groß für mein interesse an der
musik die ich spiele
ich hasse einbahnstraßen das ist ja
interessant war dass in ihm spiele ja
auch spürbar ist dass sie ein sehr
dialogischer musiker sind für sie ist
das keine einbahnstraße sondern man
würde sagen eine resonanz abjagen
ich kann nicht ohne resonanz sodann dann
höre ich auf
ja also wenn ich nur noch für mich wenn
ich nur noch für mich machen müsste
würde ich aufhören
diese resonanz erfahrung ist ja auch
eine der feinfühligkeit für politische
stimmungen es gibt von ihnen ein satz
aus jüngerer zeit der lautet die zeit in
der man passiv sein könnte ist für fast
alle vorbei
das klingt nach einer bewussten
entscheidung fast nach einer erweckung
gab es für sie ein moment wo sie sagen
ich muss aus der rolle des reinen
pianisten hinaus weil die zeit danach
ist also als reinen pianisten was auch
immer das heißen soll habe ich mich nie
gesehen dafür war ich immer schon viel
zu neugierig für wie gesagt mit menschen
und alle möglichen anderen dinge es gab
sicherlich erweckung oder oder so
initialen momente in den letzten jahren
ja die
der zusammenbruch der beinahe
zusammenbruch der weltwirtschaft war
eine initialzündung krise 2008 bei wall
street war eine initialzündung sind
daraus daraus was bei mir daraus
entstand nämlich das lesen von büchern
die ich vorher nicht gelesen aber waren
die initialzündung
der umgang mit griechenland bei der euro
krise war ein in die zündung
europäischer austeritätspolitik
natürlich die ersten artikel die ersten
zeitungsartikel über flüchtlingsboote
auf lampedusa
selbstverständlich der im herbst 2015
dass das nicht schließen von grenzen
seitens der deutschen bundesregierung
ist sehr interessant da sie sagen die
grenzen wurden nicht geöffnet es wurden
sich ja auch nicht sondern sie wollten
einfach nicht geschlossen ja also auf
das glatteis von rechten narrativen find
ich einfach weil ich einfach nicht rein
die können wir sie können sich ablegen
das nicht schließen unserer grenzen
natürlich der sachen die damit einher
ging der türkei packt das erstarken und
auf aufstehen eines eines deutschen
deutschen neofaschismus mit mit einem
jetzt parlamentarischen armen die
tatsache dass immer mehr mitglieder der
der zivilgesellschaft der dollar aus
allen bereichen aus dem politischen
bereichen aus einem plötzlich immer mehr
und mehr einfach einfach mieten mit dem
tod bedroht werden seitens von von von
rechtsextremismus
das alles sind sozusagen sich
entwickelnde initialzündungen die metro
bewegung war so eine zündung die das
zuhören ja und da kommen wir so zurück
auf den beginn einfach frauen zuzuhören
was sie erleben
das alles hat mich schon immer gemacht
aber in der intensität und was das jetzt
mit gesellschaft macht
das alles hat mich von grund auf
verändert ja das wollen wir die letzten
jahre man kann sagen dass es eine
illusion von selbstverständlichkeiten
die langsame erosion wenn sie sich
erklären wollen was diese erosion
ausgelöst hat was würde sie dann in
ihrer analyse hervortreten das kann ich
nicht erklären
sie rang gebracht als er ich frage mich
dass jeden tag was ist das interesse
dieser menschen
warum tun sie das warum tun warum reißen
bestimmte journalisten mal subtil mal
weniger subtil normen ein warum tun dass
warum tun sie das sich die
normalisierung von nicht normalen dass
das hochladen von von von einstellungen
zu legitimen meinungen
ich habe keine erklärung dafür eine
erklärung die oft gebracht wird ist eine
art status angst die angst zu verlieren
was man jetzt hat unsere zivilisation
befindet sich auf einer art
einzigartigen plateau und niemand weiß
wie es weitergehen wird und die meisten
fürchten dass es so gut nicht bleiben
kann keine status angst rechtfertigt
blanken frauenhass rechtfertigt
antisemitismus rechtfertigt rassismus
keine status angst darf
menschenverachtung rechtfertigen wenn
wir soweit sind gnade uns wer auch immer
ich höre da auch aus und no 4 ist ja
einer hashtags die sie die sie auch
verwenden da sie sagen es gibt da eine
art verständnis sperre bei ihnen im
produktiven sinne dürfen da kein schritt
in richtung verständnis dieser menschen
gehen
sehen sie da nicht auch eine blockade
gefahr blockade gegenüber wen dass man
sich auf zwei lager verhärtet die dann
nicht mehr dieses dialogische verhältnis
ein wenig das lager gehöre dass das dass
ich gegen frauen hat an diesem 10
personen rassismus ausspricht dann gehe
ich gerne zu diesem lager
wenn ich zu dem lager gehöre nicht mit
menschen an einem tisch sitzen zu wollen
der mittelfristiges und langfristiges
politisches ziel eventuell ist jemanden
wie mich umzubringen dann gehöre ich
bitte gerne zu diesen lagern ja dass ein
bekenntnis unterhaltung die auch was
unbedingt es hat ja unbedingt ich ich
halte sie um mit
unsere bundeskanzlerin zu sprechen für
alternativlos
sie sprachen von der metro bewegung was
wir sie auch eine art sensibilisierungs
schub war so wie ich das mal formulieren
das ist in der klassischen welt auch
immer ein großes und offenbar ein sehr
verschiedenes jahre leben gewesen
haben sie da in ihrem umfeld gespürt
dass der derzeit viel in bewegung gerät
also ich persönlich weiß ich persönlich
habe diese dinge nicht erlebt aber
natürlich gerät viel in bewegung
nur unsere unserer art darüber nicht
unsere art ich hab mal von jemandem
gelernt dass pauschalisierungen selten
helfen aber die diso so häufig ich höre
sehr häufig die die argumentation ja
dirigent iks ist also wirklich hat
ungeheures getan aber mensch wir dürfen
jetzt mal nicht so sehr kritisieren und
seien wir doch mal vorsichtig weil er so
ein toller maler dirigent ja er hat zum
teufel mit solchen argumenten ja dass
das würde sich wer würde sich das
leisten in jedem anderen bereich wir
erklären gerne schlechtes verhalten
durch durch sich so eine art schien die
podeste auf ja etwas was also dann
wirklich damit kann ich nichts anfangen
aber es bewegt sich in jedem
gesellschaftlichen bereich also auch in
unserem gerade sehr sehr viel gott sei
dank
wenn die sagen die zeit passiv zu sein
ist vorbei die daraus dass sie das auch
an ihre eigene zunft an die klassische
musik ja selbst werden die ein bisschen
unter politisierung verdacht steht man
hat nicht das gefühl dass sie sehr
politisch aktive sitzt im vergleich zum
theater kunst oder zur schauspielkunst
das ist so pauschal auch nicht wahr es
gibt ganz ganz ganz tolle akteure
ja es gibt institutionen die die sehr
sehr stark giftig arbeiten und für
ideale einstehen für menschen einstehen
sie haben theater genannte opernhäuser
orchester die die projekte die projekte
initiieren mit mit jugendlichen mit
geflüchteten mit was ist das gibt es
alles aber eine dringlichkeit in der
sprache die weit über das hinausgeht was
jetzt gerade ist die würde ich mir sehr
wünschen was sie was ich mir auch sehr
wünschen würde ist dass wir endlich
aufhören musik als ersatz für
politisches handeln zu begreifen denn
das ist sie nicht nur uns menschen kann
musik original einfach gar nichts also
würden sagen die idee dass wenn man
beethoven spielt schon genug gut für die
demokratie dies fundamental falsch das
ist einfach nur kindergarten gespräch
und an dem ich mich nicht beteiligen
möchte ich will sie nicht zu sehr
pieksen aber es gibt ja diese
unterscheidung zwischen vitoria als die
sie sich begreifen und den bourgeois und
der ganze klassische bereich ist nun ein
bisschen unter bourgeoisie verdacht was
auch mit dem silbersee der älteren
menschen im konzertsaal zu tun hat ich
habe das gefühl dass hier ganz bewusst
auch mit diesem muster brechen anfangen
kann kann ja also erstens auch da nicht
alles ist silber sehen
ich weigere mich auch ein bisschen
diesen die diese begriffe zu nutzen
jeder mensch jede und jeder die da im
saal sitzen da irgendwo sitzen und jetzt
in einem konkreten fall mir zuhören
schenken mir das mit das wertvollste was
sie haben nämlich ihre zeit
sie schenken mir ihre zeit und sie
schenken ihnen die zeit das ist ja genau
die art es aber wer wäre ich jetzt
pauschal man von von silbersee und es
ist wirklich das ist nicht meine sprache
und es gibt sehr viel junges publikum
das offen ist wo ich mich einfach ich
wiederhole das nochmal so ging ich mich
streuber das immer tun werde ist zu
sagen
ich spiele jetzt die ode an die freude
und damit hat es sich und das fängt ja
mit sprache an ich komme noch mal drauf
zurück musik die internationale sprache
und ich mache musik und wir wir schenken
frieden ja so so also was ist was ist
das für eine sprache musik ist eine
zustandsbeschreibung
sie beschreibt zustände sie kann sie ist
sie ist luft sie sehen geschieht
zwischen uns sie ist kein ersatz für das
für für wahrheit sie ist kein ersatz für
politisches handeln
sie ist sie sie kann niemals ersatz sein
rassismus als rassismus zu bezeichnen
ist nur ein beispiel zu nennen
und ich würde mir wünschen dass wir das
auch kommunizieren dass uns klar ist
musik kann einen sie kann aber auch
spalten und sie kann von liebe erzählen
sie kann aber auch von hass erzählen sie
kann für frieden genutzt werden und für
krieg und für alles haben wir beispiele
und wir sollten einfach anfangen er
herrlich zu reden eine weise diese musik
aber auch politisch bewertet werden zu
lassen haben sie vorgeführt als mitglied
oder als beteiligung an einer klima
aktion von extension rebellion in
oldenburg in der fußgängerzone schauen
wir uns das mal ganz kurz
[Musik]
es ist ein kleines mädchen das eine
sterbende person streichelt eigentlich
die grund menschlichste geste von allem
da liegt jemand und der andere wendet
sich hinzu und ich habe das mädchen
gesehen zum zum schluss des stücks
hatten ja auch echt den rest gegeben
diese dringlichkeit die mit dieser
bewegung einhergeht bisher die dass wenn
wir nicht aufpassen diese mädchen und
auch ihre mütter sehr bald sterben
werden sie setzen sich da ganz stark ein
fehlt ihnen denn immer noch das
bewusstsein der dringlichkeit der jahren
dass da in der gesamten teilen der
parteien der gesellschaft jahr aber vor
allen dingen in der politischen
politischen gesellschaft absolut also
was wir als als als klimapolitik
begreifen ist ist das papier nicht wert
auf dem auf dem sie geschrieben ist eine
kritik oder eine mahnung an diese
dringlichkeitsrecht ist ja immer wenn
wir zu schnell vom untergang wenn wir zu
schnell von der apokalypse reden dann
machen die menschen zu und dann werden
sie genauso angst vor sehen sie diese
dynamik auch als gefahr oder sagen sie
nein wir können das nicht deutlich genug
machen doch sie ist eine gefahr
und wir müssen eine neue sprache für
dieses problem finden
wir müssen aber wir müssen uns aber
gleichzeitig und das ist das soho ranch
wären daran auf eine einfache wahrheit
einigen
es gibt eine politische zeitrechnung wir
fangen jetzt mal langsam an und und dann
bauen wir auf und und und schauen wie
wir so gesellschaftlich weiterkommen und
es gibt keine wissenschaftliche
zeitrechnung und diese wissenschaftliche
zeitrechnung und zeitrechnung nämlich
das weltklima
das wird auf dieser zeitrechnung hier
nicht warten
da gibt es eine unwucht muss starke ja
da ist die hier einfach mal wahnsinnig
stark und sie hier fällt einfach fällt
einfach runter wenn wir nicht aufpassen
und die die mischung zwischen
verständlich sprechen mitnehmen aber
auch dringlichkeit aufzeigen
die ist so schwer aber die alternative
dazu kann nicht sein allen ernstes auf
die politische bühne zu gehen und zu
sagen so meine damen und herren wir
haben auf die wissenschaft gehört die
schlägt uns so viel vor und hier kommt
unser klima paket und das ist
worüber reden wir diese bewegung auf
dieses jahr hin sozusagen exchange in
berlin nicht wiederholt das zweite ist
for future was wollen wir denn was
wollen sie wir wollen nichts anderes als
das was die regierung hält die art so
unterschrieben das pariser abkommen ja
ist nicht dass das ist die forderung die
wie ups worüber worüber reden wir hier
und die wirkt gerissen und die wir
sehenden auges gerissen
und das ist da darüber reden wir wenn
man wenn man dann sieht dass sie die
forderung nach sie einfache forderung
nach dem was politik schon eigentlich
beschlossen hat von einer zumeist sehr
männlichen und schwer rechtslastigen und
auch ein bisschen zynischen welt als
radikal ab gestand abgestempelt wird
spricht für eine verschärfung sowohl vom
denken also von sprache dass mir exakt
die die spucke wegbleibt also die idee
dass es radikal sein soll das zu fordern
was regierung selbst beschlossen haben
das ist die verschiebung des diskurses
dies zunächst mal zu markieren geld und
ist unsere neue neue gaga realität in
der wir leben
dieser gaga realität setzten sich als
künstler doch etwas gegenüber wenn man
ihr spiel beobachtet und spiel ist ja
schon das tor zu spielen mit dem
instrument mit der notation aber auch
mit der atmosphäre sie sagen dass wenn
sie spielen den direkten kontakt mit
menschen suchen und dass sie auch andere
menschen sehen mich gelesen wie sie denn
ihr inneres auditorium aus wenn sie
spielen sind das bezugspersonen oder ist
dass menschen die sie irgendwo meinen
zug gesehen haben
das ist also es sind manchmal
bezugspersonen
es sind manchmal personen die irgendwo
gesehen habe zumeist ist es einfach die
vorstellung davon menschen sind um mich
herum also für mich ist einfach musik
und die töne und die phrasen und die
sprache im grunde parallel zum zum
menschlichen konversation
das heißt ich höre und ich spüre
konversation wenig spiele und nein liebe
zuhörerinnen und zuhörer ich bin weder
krank noch das ist das ist dass wir mit
ich einfach musik verbindet es sind
menschen aber es ist ja auch die idee
einer art durchbrechung der eigenen
gehirns wäre in die seele oder in das
denken dass anderen vielleicht so eine
art verschmelzung dass man in diesem
moment kein die leute vielleicht aber
ich bin ziemlich realist also ich bin
nicht in einer anderen sphäre wenn ich
spiele sondern ich bin ganz im gegenteil
eigentlich so im hier und jetzt wie
selten sonst in meinem alltagsleben wenn
sie vom kontakt zu anderen menschen
sprechen dann ein wichtiger anderen
jedem leben ist ein bester freund sie
haben einen besten freund plötzlich
verloren
den maler und künstler hannes malte
maler und sie haben diesem ereignis eine
eigene cd gewidmet
igor levit live in der es um trauer geht
für mich ist es oft so dass trauer etwas
ist was mit worten sehr schwer zu
erreichen ist aber die musik eigentlich
die gemäße form des trabants das kann
sein
das ist sicher so geholfen hat sie mir
nur nicht
sie schreiben in dem bei heft und das
sind zahlen die mir sehr eindrücklich
waren eine art widmen an diesem freund
dasteht weißt du dass ich bin wütend und
sehr traurig als zuweg war es so
plötzlich da war alles kaputt zerstört
restlos ich konnte nur apathisch an die
decke starren und dazwischen konzerte
spielen aber es gab nichts mehr
auch musik hat nichts geholfen die zwei
sätze die mir besonders auffielen waren
die ich konnte nur apathisch an die
decke starren und konzerte spielen
das wirkt er fast widersprüchlich diese
abgestellt hat in der trauer und doch
die fähigkeit virtuos etwas zu
interpretieren
so zynisch es klingt also in der zeit in
diesen ersten monaten war ich nicht
existent und gleichzeitig dazu
verpflichtet profi zu sein und sind
diese momente in dem man sich dazu
zwingt dann nicht auch welche der
befreiung sportler oder so beschreiben
dass ja manchmal so dass sie dann aus
der trauer hinaus treten können und in
diesem moment doch in malaysia ist es
übersetzt sich natürlich sehr viel in
das in das musikmachen aber geholfen
haben hier nur menschen geholfen hat mir
jemand der dabei dem extinction wie die
video rechts neben dem klavier lag da
hat das nämlich organisiert und oldie
oliver ist oder war
hannes ältester engst mit mit einer
ältesten engsten freunde und über diesen
über den tod unseres gemeinsamen engsten
freunde sind wir so eng
zusammengewachsen wie man es kaum
beschreiben kann
und das wiederum war ein geschenk mit
eines der schönsten größten geschenke
dieser dieser dieses einschneidenden
moment es war diese freundschaft das hat
das hat geholfen menschen haben geholfen
musik war ein tunnel aber
geholfen da zweifle ich verrückt sie das
heißt weil ich denke ich denke seltener
an ihn aber wenn ich an ihn denke ist
der schmerz genauso wie vor dreieinhalb
jahren wären wir mit schriftstellern
spricht und auch den reaktionen die sie
auf ihr werk erhalten als reaktion ich
bin nicht allein in meinem gefühl das
ist das was literatur kann wenn man
diese cd gehört das ging mir zumindest
selber so hatte ich das gefühl ich bin
nicht allein in diesem schmerz es ist ja
auch eine form der teilung und wenn man
sagt erledigt hat das gespielt in einem
moment in dem er in der trauer war dann
dann überträgt sich doch etwas was was
therapeutisch sein kann
das war eben das was geholfen hat war
dass sich nicht allein fühlen aber ich
kann nicht mit musik ich kann nicht mit
ich kann versuchen zustände meine
zustände zu beschreiben ich hab noch
nicht mal die deutungshoheit darauf
darüber was für zuständig da gerade
beschreiben denn ich kann eines fühlen
sie werden etwas ganz anderes fühlen
also ich kann zustände meine zustände
irgendwie in dieses instrument legen
aber nicht allein sein das steht und
fällt mit menschen für mich sie haben
also ich versuche das muss verstehen
dass glaube ich ganz wesentlicher
gedanke andere menschen haben eine
andere form von heilsamer präsenz als
die isolation die aus seiner musiker und
und das sind zwei ganz verschiedene
swiss re sind ein wort das sie immer
wieder verwenden wenn sie ihr spiel
beschreiben ist dass der unmittelbarkeit
seien sehr romantisches ideal der sens
der nähe der glut man könnte sagen einer
verlorenheit in fokussierter intensität
ja wobei ich nicht nur dass damit meine
ich meine da so da gehe ich total mit
sehr romantische idee ich meine damit
aber auch etwas ganz eigentlich von noch
viel einfacher das heißt dass ich meine
damit ich ich ich mag beim musik machen
wenn es wenn es in anführungszeichen
leicht und direkt kommt ja und das ist
das allerschwerste miles davis hat
gesagt man ist es echt schwer so zu
klingen wie man selbst
ich würde einen schritt weiter
weitertreiben und sagen das ist das
allerschwerste mit fast und beinahe
unerreicht passte so zu klingen wie man
wie man selbst was ist mein eigener ton
und ich versuche je weiter ich komme
immer mehr und mehr barrieren abzubauen
um zum immer einfacheren und
unmittelbaren thron zu kommen ja er muss
am ende so leicht sein das ist klopp
macht und der ton ist da nicht so nicht
so nicht durch irgendwelche tricksereien
ich will nicht darum darüber nachdenken
aus welchem winkel ich meine finger
wohnen welche taste
drehe ich will eigentlich eine eine idee
hier haben und einfach machen
da ist er und das sind die musiker die
mir auch am allermeisten bedeuten und
die auch sicherlich nati durch also
idole für mich sind sind die musiker
über den ich das gefühl habe hey das ist
da ist der weg von dir zum ton wenn
überhaupt dann so kurz ist eine 1
wertung der verschmelzung ein gewitter
ist im grunde wenden wenn es ist im
grunde genommen wenn ich jetzt etwas
nehmer und sage da ist ganz einfach und
und und der fall auf gut durch das feuer
total drauf ab deswegen sind so
pianisten für mich wie für news monk
oder oder ein beethoven spiel eine sato
schnabel oder fred herrscht der große
jazz pianist oder andere das ist das ist
da ist es ja wissen es gibt es gibt ja
zu sagen auch so mystische
beschreibungen von solchen zu stellen
dass man sagt für das nicht über
überreizen aber ich spiele nicht den ton
sondern ich bin eher tun
man ist vollkommen in dieser musik und
man hat gar nicht mehr das gefühl dass
man sie erzeugt sondern verkörpert sie
vollkommen ja wenn sie jetzt noch das
wort mystisch rausnehmen gehe ich voll
mit gerechter voll mit es ist ja sehr
schön wenn sie denn sagen dieses
intensität dass das klavier ein
instrument ist dass ich vielleicht mit
der geige am ehesten dafür eignet da
kann man das mit jedem ins tor das
klavier hat ja eine eine wunderbare
eigenschaft anders als die geige und da
spreche ich aus eigener erfahrung ich
habe mal versucht geige zu spielen
ich versuche es traurigerweise noch
immer und ich klinge wirklich suboptimal
das klavier hat die tolle eigenschaft
dass jede und jeder jede sie alle hier
im studio egal vollkommen egal ob sie ob
sie jemals ein ein klavier gesehen haben
oder nicht ja sind rücken auf eine taste
ist ganz einfach klopp runter und egal
ob sie es können oder nicht sie haben
sofort ein erfolgserlebnis das
instrument dann erklingt er sofort er ab
dem ab der ersten sekunde
das für kinder so wahnsinnig toll
deswegen gehen deswegen ist es so
wunderbar kinder an das klavier
heranzuführen weil sie sofort das gefühl
haben ich habe es geschafft
gratifikation ist unmittelbar kann man
sagen absolut sensationell ich hab' ich
glaube dass das haben sie vielleicht
noch mit atrium geht es auch so dass man
nicht wirklich ohne ohne jede ironie
es geht auch vielleicht mit mit einer
trommel so also sie machen und es kommt
was raus mit dem klavier kommt einfach
ein schöner klang sofort danach wird's
schwer
das heißt diese diese dieses
unmittelbare ist einfach diesem
instrument glaube ich ja in die indy in
die dna rein geschrieben worden
sie haben auch mal mit diesem instrument
sehr gehadert weil sie das gefühl haben
das war für ihn zu limitiert das ist
etwas was wenn man sie spielen sieht man
eigentlich kaum glauben kann nicht das
instrument war limitiert
aber die welt in der ich aufwuchs
erschien limitiert war mir zu wenig als
sozialer kontext als als als sozialer
intellektueller emotionaler kontext war
mir einfach zu wenig verstehe und wie
waren sie dann mit 17
ich war wahrscheinlich ganz anders als
jemand stellt sich also eine eine
wunderkind und das sind ein
schreckliches wort aber doch eine eine
hochbegabten kindheit man das vor sehr
konzentriert sie sprachen von dieser
leichtigkeit mit der sie selbst sein
können als jetzt zunächst einmal ein
unglaubliches technisches können voraus
erst dann kommt das hier erst ins spiel
und das bedeutet 68 stunden überzahl
deutet einfach sehr sehr viel arbeit
aber das meine ich es ist das ist das
beinahe auf unerreichbare art und weise
das allerschwerste wie gesagt wie das
gesagt hat das ist einfach echt wirklich
schwer und es verlangt sehr sehr viel
arbeit aber mir war damals so im alter
von 16 17 18 und mit einem james bond
film zu sprechen die welt nicht genug
ich habe eine andere musik gehört ich
habe mich von anderen dingen irgendwie
inspirieren lassen und konnte mit kaum
jemandem darüber reden
da hat von befangenheit in der seehäuser
gefahr
ich wollte schon immer gefahren wir
zeigen jetzt mal ein stück wo sie ganz
sie selbst sind und es ist doch etwas
gefährliches weil es sehr schwierig ist
eine aufführung von frederiks schewski
da sind sie glaube ich ganz sie selbst
[Musik]
herr levit die erste assoziation ich
fürchte die mit ihnen gar nicht gefallen
ist da bietet einer mit tönen seine ganz
starke versunkenheit in dieser in diesem
spiel die versunkenheit gefällt mir das
okay aber es gibt für sie gar nicht die
idee dass die musik auch mit einer sagen
das wäre der transzendenz in besonderer
weise in kontakt stehen können doch
absolut aber für mich in mir ist wir
sind menschen mit ihren gefühlen und
ihren emotionen transzendent genug das
ist ein schöner satz in der immanenz das
miteinander erschweren sie den weg in
die transzendenz schauen sie sehen sie
mein erster gedanke gerade war ohne bart
ist echt komisch an ist das eigentlich
als vier jahre her etwas über vier jahre
das ist die welt noch da waren die welt
noch bequem fast in ordnung und doch ist
das ja ein sehr politisches stück das
sie das spielen das ist sind 36
variationen auf ein revolutionslied aus
chile pueblo unido das volk vereint und
vielleicht ist das nicht zu stark zu
sagen ohne diese komposition wären sie
gar nicht pianist geworden biografisch
sie ich hätte aufgehört die begegnung
mit friedrichs musik das war eben ist
ein zeitgenössischer komponisten
wahrscheinlich gar nicht der legendär
ist ein harter knochen lebt in brüssel
und ist einer der bedeutendsten meiner
meinung nach bedeutendsten komponisten
unserer zeit und auch darüber hinaus die
begegnung mit seiner musik oder alles
was daraus entstand war mit ein grund
weshalb ich damals mit so 16 17 nicht
gesagt aber auch wisst ihr was leute ich
liebe musik auch weiterhin aber ich mach
was anderes
ein grund dass ich das nicht gemacht
aber weil sie beginnen mit diesem stück
und wie kann ich mir diese begegnung
forscher man kann sagen da ästhetischen
raum der sich öffentlich kenne oder man
kann sagen das ist ein revolutionslied
auf piano
da öffnet sich mir auch eine form nicht
selbst wo diverse arbeiten entstehen ich
war damals kein politischer politischer
mensch viel zu jung
also sage ich jetzt viel zu jungen ja
wenn die wii
[Musik]
wie kleinkariert der satz klingt wenn
man bedenkt dass eine der dass ein
mensch wie ingrid attenberg im alter von
16 es schafft gerade die komplette
westliche westliche klimapolitik um 180
grad zu drehen und ja also ich war mit
16 nicht in der form nach ihren für für
die probleme für diese war ein absolutes
kind und dann bin ich diesem stück
begegnet und das stück hat sich erstmal
umgehauen rein als pianistisches
erlebnis ja ja ich habe es in der
bibliothek gehört in der musikhochschule
in hannover und war einfach so einfach
fertig danach
und dann habe ich einfach durch durch
eine kleine recherche die e mail adresse
dieses komponisten gefunden und hab
einfach geschrieben und gesagt so guten
tag ich bin also lernt er und ich
irgendwann mal spiele ich das stück es
hat dann acht jahre gedauert und bis
dahin würden sie was nämlich schreiben
mit freundlichen grüßen
und dann schreibt er mir zurück und sagt
ja wenn jemand findet er dafür zeit
mache ich es und so entstand dann ein
kontakt getroffen haben wir uns viel
viel später jetzt nämlich 2012 aber die
begegnung mit seiner musik und ihm das
lesen über ihn das verstehen dieses
politischen kontext ist mein meine
begegnung mit komponisten die mit mit
denen er sehr eng war morton feldman
karlheinz stockhausen etc woody guthrie
die ganze die ganze die ganze songwriter
bewegung der usa das alles entstand aus
der begegnung mit friedrich chefs musik
und das war für mich wie eine art
ja wieso frischblut in die in die venen
was an diesem stück ja auch eine
wahrheit ist es unspielbar schwer nicht
hat dieses thema ja aber die andere
variationen charmant weil sie das als
unspielbar ankündigen und dann zeigen
sie das thema aber worauf ich hinaus
will ist sie scheinen ja auch sagen wir
mal einen mount everest drang in sich zu
haben wenn es nicht wirklich schwer ist
interessiert sie das nicht und als
16-jähriger haben sie etwas gefunden was
man gesagt hat dass es so schnell das
kann selbst über liebe nicht spielen ich
konnte das nicht
das hat ein bisschen gedauert ich habe
also es geht nicht um es geht mir nicht
nur um schwer aber ich habe schon ja
sonst und errang habe ich absolut herren
auch die anderen geschichten die man
über sich liest die sind ja schon auch
in seinen ehrgeiz tier wenn sie wollen
nehmen sie 30 kilo auf mit einem cardio
training ab das heißt sie setzen sich
nicht kleiner sondern ist interessiert
sie nur wenn es in die absoluten
grenzbereiche ja aber dazu muss ich
wirklich in allen ehren so sagen ich
hasse ziele ich setze mir nie ziele
ich habe noch nie in meinem leben
erzählen gedacht noch nie nicht nicht
einen tag durchlaufe prozesse und dann
durch laufe ich den nächsten prozess ja
das hat sein gutes und das hat auch sein
nicht so gut ist ich könnte es mir nicht
so gerne ja also ich hab irgendwie wir
haben diese aufnahme gemacht ich könnte
jetzt sagen
fantastisch ich habe diese aufnahme
gemacht jetzt mal kurz ein bisschen
pause und mal sortieren
mein erster gedanke ist ok what's next
ja und das ist
ich bin ich bin ein prozess mensch ich
bin nicht besonders gut darin gut zu mir
selbst zu sein wenn es kein ziel gibt
ihres schaffens zu uns hier werden sehr
breites report fall gibt es doch eine
art gravitationszentrum und das ist
beethoven sie haben die sonaten von
beethoven jetzt mal ganz eingespielt
gerade erschienen irgendwie spürt man ja
als künstler mit gewissen anderen
komponisten besondere verbindung was war
diese besondere verbindung wo sie sagten
das ist nicht das ist meine goldader der
bleibe ich treu
das ist einfach die musik die nicht 24
stunden am tag 7 tage die woche
begleitet in der einen oder anderen
frauen aber es könnte auch mozart sein
oder jemand anders eben nicht geworden
sie würden aber nicht sagen ich könnte
den finger drauf legen warum beethoven
nein zu mir
er spricht als ein habe ich habe das
gefühl ich habe vorhin gesagt ich suche
gefahren ich war schon besucht und die
suche das mir unbekannte permanent und
gleichzeitig ist dass die musik in der
ich den allergrößten schutzraum spüre
sie sprechen ganz wundervoll von der
barrierefreiheit von elektro fans musik
das bringt ein gewisser freiheitsdrang
eine offenheit es gibt von dem
generationsgenossen beethoven heldin im
gleichen jahr geboren diesen
wundervollen satz komm ins offene freund
ist dass die gefahr die sie suchen
dieses ozeanische offene dass man
erstmal bewältigen muss ja ich würde zum
umformulieren des kommens unbekannte com
mit unseren bekannte ich will immer ins
unbekannte
das ist ja sehr typisch für diese zeiten
und 1818 150 das waren revolutionsjahren
das war ein aufbruch sei es natürlich
auch zeiten der deutschen hochkultur
würden sie sagen dass in diesem raum
dieser offenheit dieser unbekanntheit
drang besonders stark war vielleicht
dass ich meine jemand jemand wie
beethoven der so heiß drauf war
nennen wir es beim namen die welt neu zu
erfinden
sowohl instrumental ich mein der hat ja
er hat zum beispiel klavierbauer
regelrecht aufgedrängt das instrument
weiterzuentwickeln gedrängt und mit der
entwicklung des klaviers entwickelte
sich auch sein kompositionsstil immer
weiter ein prozess mensch könnte man
sagen wo sich das land neige nicht zu
vergleichen aber mit aber ja und
klar da wird die welt permanent neu
erfunden permanent auf basis von wissen
auf basis von bewusstsein wo komme ich
her baue ich einfach eine neue welt auf
es gibt ich komme wieder auf wo sony
weil das also einer schon so eine art
held ist für mich ein bisschen erzählen
perkussionistin viele menschen schoko
sony war ende des 19 anfang des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts ein pianist ein
komponist ein denker einer der
bedeutendsten musiker seiner zeit lehrer
halb italiener halb deutscher
italienischer vater deutscher mutter war
einfach ein ja für mich einer der
bedeutendsten revolutionärsten musik
figuren aller zeiten auch ein denker hat
der musik ein denker der musik wo sony
schrieb anfang das also 1950 zwischen
1916 und glaube ich dann die letzte
fassung eine abhandlung über die
ästhetik der neuen tonkunst und das ist
ein ganz kleines büchlein 60 seiten
gefühlte oderstädter was mehr und es ist
wie so eine art jetzt nutze ich den
begriff seiner bibel für mich und da
stehen er plädiert und er kämpft für die
freie musik das ist das buch wo er woher
die musik als tönen der luft bezeichnet
und da spricht sehr sehr viel über die
rolle des interpreten und die rolle oder
die möglichkeiten die musik hat und da
gibt es einen satz drin wobei sony sagt
ich hoffe ich zitiere das richtig die
aufgabe des schaffenden besteht darin
eigene gesetze zu erschaffen und nicht
den gesetzen anderer zu folgen
und wenn der schaffende nur den gesetzen
anderer folgt hört er auf ein schaffen
da zu sein und die wiederholung ist
immer stumpf in diesem sinne der status
quo ist der musik tot
ich glaube ich hier gibt es eine für
mich persönlich eine irgendwie nach
parallele zum
dann wieder so mal tag weil ich dabei
eine welt die sich nicht verhindert
stirbt aber es ist interessant dass sie
diesen freiheitsdrang mit dem
unbekannten verbunden verbinden nur dort
wo es noch keine regeln gibt laut für
sie die frage dass es wiederum sehr
romantisch wird ja sagen aber ich bin
kein ich bin kein angst mensch aber vor
dem erreichen eines status quo habe ich
angst
wenn man diese komponisten universen
zusammen da gibt es ja mal zwei große
trennung es gibt zum beispiel die
robusten und es gibt die deutschen sie
sind jetzt ein deutsch russe kann man
sagen und sie wahr sind eigentlich sehr
auch mit beethoven in diesem dieser
deutschen kultur verankert kann man das
dann eigentlich sagen dass da jemand
deutsch klingt oder russisch oder ist
das unsinn im übrigen auch noch juni
wahrscheinlich interessantes wird so so
so häufig mal nicht nicht benannt das
bin ich auch bin ich vor allem auch das
würde mich auch interessieren
machen wir gleich so aber ich mich es
ist jetzt wirklich nicht nicht mehr auf
nicht gegen sie oder ist keine wertung
der frage mich langweilen diese begriffe
ich möchte darüber ich kannte ich habe
zu diesen begriff nicht so viel zu sagen
aber es gab ja als sie nach deutschland
jahren aus russland eine liebesbeziehung
die unmittelbar war das war die
offizielle sprache und das ist ja auch
ein werk der kultur was war denn das am
deutschland dass sie so geliebt habe man
kann dir sagen weil es die anderen
kinder sprachen aber das scheint ja noch
viel mehr im spiel gewesen zu sagen sie
bücher es war es war es war es war
einfach der es war der klang der sprache
ich bin in der ersten schultage ohne ein
wort deutsch sprechen zu können bin ich
nach hause gekommen sagt mal papa also
ich werde besser deutsch sprechen als
alle meine klassenkameraden alle das war
mein anspruch und ich habe mich einfach
in diese sprache verliebt aber
das war ja ein ziel dann auf jeden fall
das war ein ziel jetzt haben sie mich
erwischen
aber das ist ein land in dem ich lebe
das ich sehr
die wiesn bin das ist mein es ist mein
zuhause und es sind die engsten und die
wichtigsten sie einen die tiefsten
wunden zufügen
in diesen wunden zufügen werde mich
interessiert ihre familie seine jüdische
familie sie kamen aus seinem kontingent
gab es damals eine regelung aus dass
eventuell nach deutschland gab es in
ihrer familie jemals eine spannung die
auch verbalisiert wurde zwischen der
idee aus zu weil auszuwandern und
ausgerechnet nach deutschland aus zu
klagen nicht dann nicht das ich mich
erinnere dass das dass das ich habe auch
bis anfang mai bis 21 22 23
diese fragen auch nie nie stellen müssen
bis dann die ersten die ersten runden
kam und die ersten verletzungen und
plötzlich wohl systeme das heißt in
ihrer kindheit in hannover war die
tatsache dass sie aus einer jüdischen
familie stammen für niemann thematisch
weder für die schule noch für sie noch
für ihre familie in meinem privatleben
nicht existent das änderte sich später
gibt es da ein signal wohl sagen ich
habe das begriffen zum beispiel von
hannah arendt gibt es viele beschreibung
ist sage ich hab mir war das immer ganz
egal bis ich dann irgendwann auf
menschen traf die mich haben spüren
lassen dass sich juden und von dort hat
sich das geändert es gab 2000 es gab
2011 ein ein sehr gepflegtes an essen
bei ihm zu hause wo mir am anfang
vierzig jahre alte jurist der mich
überhaupt nicht kannte nach einem fünf
minuten im gespräch den satz sagte ich
dürfe nie vergessen zu einer
bevölkerungsgruppe zu gehören die hier
zwei lebt hier zu leben aber nicht mehr
vorgesehen war ende des zitats
das war bewusst in meinem leben die
erste runde und dies nie verheilt und
das macht was mit dir und von denen habe
ich dann über die jahre einige erfahren
das ist eine interessante formulierung
die nicht vorgesehen war man könnte sich
ja doppelt deuten könnte sagen
einerseits er sollte nicht mehr hier
sein oder aus der tatsache dass eine
auslöschung drohte erwächst auch eine
gewisse verantwortung so wolf gemeint
das war als eine ausgangs gemeint wenn
wir heute im jahr 2009 10 24 jahre
nachdem ich hier nach nachdem meine
familie und ich hergekommen sind 24
jahre allerengsten und austausches und
und 24 jahre meines lebens in diesem
land heute ihre kollegen sagen dass mein
natürliches zuhause israel sei weil ich
sage ja jude unter meinesgleichen zitat
ende
das macht mich sprachlos und es entsteht
ein gefühl von enthaltung dass man noch
nackter als nacktes und völlig während
eines raumes sitzt und und es wird
einfach du bist du bist du bist im
grunde deine existenz beraubt
in diese rollen verschiebung kann man ja
auch sagen mit dem jüdischen leben im
deutschsprachigen raum nicht nur in
deutschland aber auch in deutschland ist
ja die letzten jahre auch einiges
passiert sie waren immer glaube ich sehr
zurückhaltend mit dieser jüdischen
identität bin kein religiöser mensch
aber hannah arendt zb sagte wenn ich als
jude angegriffen werde werde ich mich
als jude wären ist das ein standpunkt
den sie auch annehmen würde ich würde
ihn annehmen ich würde ihn aber ergänzen
und sagen ich weigere mich dass wir
hatten das eingangs ich weigere mich
vehement begriffe die jeder für sich
anders sind die aber all die aber die
eine idee der menschenverachtung 1 das
vorhin genannt antisemitismus
antifeminismus rassismus was was immer
ich weigere mich diese begriffe für sich
alleine zu besprechen
entweder wir besprechen alles und wir
besprechen gar nichts weil es keine form
der ausgrenzung gibt die in irgendeiner
form war ja das wäre hervorgehoben sind
weil es wenig dinge gibt in meinem leben
die mich so wütend machen wütend machen
als die aufstellung von
opfer hier reichen ja wieso dieses
dieses sprenger spiel mache ich nicht
mit
das ist innerhalb der jüdischen
erfahrung europas keine ganz leicht zu
vermittelnde position weil man sagt das
ist keine form der ausgrenzung wie jede
andere das ist eine spezielle die hatte
auch spezielle folgen die kann man nicht
gleichsetzen mit sexismus oder rassismus
in anderer form ganz einfach mal ist die
show ergab beispielsweise als erfahrung
der eine andere form der auslöschung war
die ver.di die man nicht in gleicher
weise daran war sie aber ich bin nicht
ich bin nicht in diesen zeiten groß
geworden und wenn jetzt und wenn wenn
ich werde ich kommen
ich wachse in einer zeit auf wo frauen
mit dem mid mid mid mit dem tod bedroht
werden wo muslime mit dem tod bedroht
werden wo juden bedroht werden
die jüdische friedhöfe dem vandalismus
zum opfer fallen wo moscheen angegriffen
werden wo jeden tag eine gibt jeden tag
frauen häusliche gewalt erfahren jeden
einzelnen tag und gleichzeitig
frauenhäuser schließen das hat ricarda
lang bei den bayern beim jetzigen
parteitag der grünen so sensationell
hingestellt das ist die zeit finde ich
aufwachse und ich werde nicht meine zeit
erklären ausschließlich mit der sprache
damit den verständnis einer zeit in der
ich nicht am leben weil ich bin heute am
leben und opfer hierarchien sind
wirklich nicht ich weigere mich damit zu
machen
in der zeit in der wir jetzt sind und
die verschärft sich das ist eine
geteilte wahrnehmung die man auch sehr
gut stützen kann wenn einsatz nur dazu
ich würde mir ich würde das dass es auch
keine relativierung nur
menschenverachtung ist
menschenverachtung ist eine
menschenverachtung und aussprache werden
taten und solange ich auch in
allerkleinsten bereich irgendeinen
werkzeug habe um dagegen zu kämpfen
werde ich es tun ist denn für sie eine
situation gesellschaftlicher art
absehbar wo sie sagen ich hänge meine
karriere als pianist einen nagel ich
setze sie aus weil ich das gefühl habe
dass anderes jetzt dringlicher wäre
sie haben eine gewisse skepsis bezüglich
der kraft der musik als musik heilen zu
wirken dass sie sagen nein jetzt ist der
punkt klavier spielen ist nicht das was
ich tun sollte ich sollte etwas anderes
tun
ja das kann ich mir vorstellen
ich möchte es mir nicht vorstellen aber
ich kannte es nur vorstellen dass es
passieren kann ja habe ich glaube wir
sind auch nicht mehr
wir leben auch nicht mehr in einer zeit
wo ist die gefahr gibt einer
unangenehmen neuen rechten realität ich
glaube wir sind mittendrin
es klingt so als ob sie diesen gedanken
schon mal fast erwogen hätten für sich
das ist ein gedanke den ich mir stelle
den ich aber überhaupt nicht für für für
das ist nichts was ich jetzt was ich
jetzt mache aber das ist ein
theoretischer gedanke demi stelle dann
ich möchte der tag an dem ich aufwache
mit dem gefühl über die dächer meiner
meine liebsten fliegen geschoss oder sie
sind sie sind ihres teams nicht mehr
sicher ist der tag an dem ich nicht mehr
ruhig werde klavier üben kann es denn
für sie sagen ihr engagement auf twitter
dass er wirklich beachtlich ist die
haben sich über 30
aber es ist ein ist ein einstiger teil
das ist doch für sie im prinzip die form
politischer teilnahme die ihnen derzeit
am effektivsten erscheint
das ist ein teil der politischen
teilnahme ich bin genauso viel analog
unterwegs wie digital
ich versuche so genau so viel an
menschen zu helfen wo ich es kann und
mit ihnen zu sprechen wie ich mich
digital äußerungen es ist also ein
aspekt nicht das ist es ist es ist unser
leben dass die geteilte auch nichts was
man jetzt irgendwie hilft auch nichts
dass jetzt wie einfach abzuschalten und
zu sagen das interessiert mich nicht wer
unser ganzer analoger unsere analoge
umwelt ist ja von von dem von den
digitalen beeinflusst aber es ist nicht
meine ganze mein aktivismus beschränkt
sich nicht auf das digital weil sie
davon sprachen menschen zu helfen herr
levit die letzte frage ja viele klavier
spielenden menschen schauen uns zu viele
klavier eltern ihre erfahrung wenn man
eines vermeiden soll auf dem weg zum
pianisten als eltern oder als spielen da
was soll man da vermeiden angst ist das
für sie etwas was sie selbst gespürt
haben ja wo 44
vielen dank dass sie daran und echte
andere töne für uns angeschlagen haben
danke vielen dank
nächste woche diskutiere ich mit der
österreichischen philosophen liz hirn
aus und dem deutsch amerikanischen
literaturwissenschaftler hans ulrich
gumbrecht die frage nach der moral nimmt
in der beurteilung von kunst kultur und
politik ja unserer wortwahl selbst immer
größeren raum ein gut so und wenn ja für
wen
jetzt gleich gibt es ein wunderbares
schauspiel porträt in der sternstunde
kunst der film zeigt wie aus dem bitter
armen archibald lied aus südengland der
gefeierte hollywood-star cary grant
wurde viel vergnügen damit und denken
sie weiter
[Musik]